Tom's with us in Sacramento California
hey Tom how are you good how you doing
better than I deserve sir how can I help
I was calling about Heidi and we just
finished up that PU and week nine to
talk about Heidi I'm all in for it but
my wife struggles with it and because it
put us behind on some of our bills so
asking you what you thought about it and
where we should go with the tithing so
you went to Financial Peace University
at your local church yes we did you all
attend that church yes ah and so you're
Christians yeah obey sod okay good folks
yeah I'm wonderful yeah all right um
well then I'm going to give you a smart
aleck answer first and that is what your
wife thinks about this what you think
about it and what I think about it
doesn't matter
uh-huh is believers what we should be
concerned about is what God thinks about
it yes okay and so that that's thing one
thing to then is if God is telling us to
give a tenth of our income according to
Scripture he is off the top before we do
anything else to our local church why
would he have us to do that didn't the
Lord well to trust in him that's good
but also because he's trying to change
us into givers uh-huh he wants to
activate that part of our heart that is
most like him and that is the generous
giving graceful part of our heart and
and by the way he says he's in essence
is saying a loving father is looking at
you looking at me looking at your wife
and saying hey kiddos the best way to
live your life is be generous and so I'm
telling you to start before you do
anything being generous it changes you
and you're going to have a better life
because of that and so you're trusting
him that he is advising you something
not for your harm but that is for your
good yes and so in a sense to say
otherwise is a lack of trust now we all
face that we all face those questions
and when you look at the budget and say
we don't have any money and if I tithe
then something is not going to get paid
ah that's a tough one that's a really
tough one you know what I'll tell you
having done budgets for 25 years
I also think if you're doing a written
budget that that's probably not true
okay because most people that can make
it on ninety percent or can make it on
100 percent can make it on ninety
percent now if you're way upside down
and you already aren't able to pay all
your bills tithing would just add to
that but if you're able to pay your
bills today and tae-young keeps you from
paying your bills
there's something else wrong going on in
your life and in your budget that's what
I find because 10 percent tempers it's
not that big a number yeah I mean what's
your what's your all's in household
income one hundred twenty-five thousand
a year okay and how much debt do you
have uh we're about ninety six thousand
and it on what Howard stupid things the
credit cards and NiO taken loans out and
stuff like that how much do you owe on
your cars always that's it on our cars
we've paid our cars off that's good news
okay yep all right well here's what I
would say if God is saying in his word
to me as his child my loving heavenly
father's looking at me and saying hey
kiddo the best way to do this is to pay
is to pay off the top before you do
anything a tenth because it changes you
if that's really what he's saying and I
do believe that is it and he cares
deeply about me this is not about my
salvation he's not saying if you don't
give I'm not going to love you it's
nothing like that
it's and so he's just saying this is the
best way to live if he's saying that and
I believe that that's true then I've got
to make the moves in my work habits a
working extra I've got to sell stuff
I've got to get this budget under
control to start doing that as soon as
possible
not because God's going to strike me
with lightning or something but because
my Heavenly Father who loves me says hey
this is the best way to live this is the
best way to live I came to that
conclusion early in my Christian walk as
an adult because that's how I met God
and started tithing and I tithe all the
way into bankruptcy court in although
out I mean when I have $10 as a dollar
and I remember the first time I made
$10,000 and I tied the thousand now that
I thought I was going to pass out
I just gave $1,000 the church freaked me
out man
and so um and then I figured out I
wasn't give it at the church at all I
was just returning it to God because it
wasn't really mine to start with and
that's how the deal went down so you
know I'm gonna highly suggest not
legalistically and not like some kind of
Christian rule follower or something but
that you guys look in your hearts and
say alright if we're not there today how
quickly do we get there because this is
what God says is the best way to live
and then you guys go get there as fast
as you possibly can but again it's not a
Salvation issue and it's not brownie
points in heaven or something like that
but it's just the best way to live your
life this generosity thing off the top
before we do anything else it changes
our perception of money